en perú la presión internacional crecía
en contra de manuel merino la agregación
local de las naciones unidas- mostró su
preocupación por la actuación de las
fuerzas del orden durante las protestas
que tienen lugar desde hace varios días
tras la destitución de martín vizcarra
es necesario recordar que la utilización
arbitraria e indiscriminada de las armas
no letales vulnera el principio de
proporcionalidad e infringe los
estándares internacionales no es el
único grupo internacional de derechos
humanos en expresar su preocupación
frente a la situación peruana human
rights watch y la organización de
estados américanos ya han pedido al
tribunal constitucional de perú que
aclare la constitucionalidad del proceso
de destitución así como estas
declaraciones no reconocen a merino como
nuevo presidente tampoco lo han hecho
los gobiernos de colombia y argentinas
que se han pronunciado sobre la crisis
en perú además países como eeuu y el
reino unido han reiterado su posición a
favor de nuevas elecciones es importante
que la voz del pueblo peruano se escuche
a través de elecciones libres
no era violencia en la región chile y
paraguay son las excepciones que
reconocen al gobernante como autoridad
el gobierno de este último expresó sus
deseos de éxitos a manuel merino para la
conclusión del mandato presidencial 2016
2021 mientras el gobierno de chile le
deseo un buen desempeño en su gestión a
pesar de la gran inestabilidad política
que afronta su país merino no ha hecho
ninguna aparición en público ni ha
emitido algún pronunciamiento en las
últimas horas
[Música]